there's nothing scarier than the
truth if you're a True Believer in the
Paranormal then you likely know this
couple Ed and line and if you don't you
might have heard about movies they
inspired like the con the haunted n The
Haunting their story spawn a Cinematic
Universe that Rivals the success of well
the main one you think of when I say the
words Cinematic Universe but this isn't
the first time their stories were told
so how did this very specific very scary
Conjuring Universe become so
[Music]
[Applause]
successful Ed Warren was a demonologist
Lorraine Warren was a trans medium
better known as a clairvoyant together
for decades they were paranormal
investigators looking into some of the
most famous occurrences of the occult
all over the world this was just another
haunted house and we didn't even realize
that six people had been murdered in
that house of the fail family they
investigated hauntings of small children
demonic presences and even a werewolf
which is all detailed on their
incredible website that has case files
for some of their most famous
investigations this one in particular
was no joke as Lorraine explains in this
feature from war Brothers this is the
worst thing I'm not going to I'm not
going to stare at it though that has
done bad harm on a lot of people now why
would they have a creepy doll on display
like that well after the Warren close
the case they would often take the
haunted objects back home in order to
keep them safe from the public they kept
them in their basement in Monroe
Connecticut which went on to become an
occult Museum considered to be the most
haunted area in the world that's what I
would say I would say that it is without
even mentioning Hollywood I think anyone
would say that their story has all of
the ingredients to make an awesome movie
but when Hollywood has tackled their cas
cases most of the films have left the
Warren out of the narrative like there
are roughly 30 Amityville movies about
this haunted house where in 1976 the
Warren and their crew investigated and
took this ghost photo of a boy who had
been murdered
there but none of these films were
specifically about the couple the Warren
were portrayed on the small screen in
1991's the haunted which can't I just
say excellent title but they weren't put
at the center of any story until 2013's
The Conjuring the movie that changed
everything for the horror genre and
that's not hyperbole The Conjuring is
the highest grossing horror franchise of
all time but before we dive into the
boring financials of the universe let's
first talk about why the conjuring
[Music]
worked the trailer for the film lays on
the concept of cander really thick it's
not a haunting it's not a possession but
the truth it was marketing gold of
course but the truth was also incredibly
important to the creative team Lorraine
Warren was a Consultants on the film and
she became close friends with her
on-screen counterpart the subjects of
the film The Peron family who were
haunted and eventually possessed by a
witch named baath Sheba are still very
much alive and have given chilling
interviews with Warner Brothers like in
this other feature I doubt very much
that I will be willing to see the film
for the the same reason I'm unwilling to
ever go back to the house Jesus Christ
of course creative Liberties are always
taken but the team had a lot of
reverence for the
[Music]
truth reflecting on the film recently
with Entertainment Weekly director James
Juan said that one of the things he
wanted to do is to treat it like a
straightforward drama and not even a
horror film and that's pretty clear
because the story is heartfelt the
acting is sincere and grounded and it
was masterfully shocked this is true of
pretty much every movie in The Conjuring
Universe they all try to keep an
emotional story at the center whether
it's romantic familial or friendship and
they all have extremely creative
[Music]
scares and if you have beef with that
statement then you can take it up with
my electric pill because after
rewatching the movies to make this video
I have not been able to sleep with the
light off for days and I really wish I
was shoken but I am so
scared the first 10 minutes of The
Conjuring are primarily focused on
building out who the Warren are through
the Annabel case you know the one about
the extremely haunted doll that Lorraine
was talking about earlier bad harm on a
lot of people it looks a little
different in the movie but it's a great
way to establish that Ed and Lorraine
are accomplished paranormal
investigators while giving the audience
a quick hit of scares before moving on
to the actual subject of the movie The
Peron family it also plant seeds to show
that there are more stories to tell in
this world like in The Conjuring we get
glimpses of Annabelle in The Conjuring 2
we get a few moments with the Zoot Trope
of the Crooked Man in Annabelle
Creations we get a photo that briefly
features the nun it's like the films are
constantly referencing their deep
Archive of Case Files but of course no
device is more beautiful for building
out a universe than the occult Museum
it's like the vity Stones times a
million and the film's creators knew
this director James Juan even said that
it occurred to them early on there's
already a superhero Universe why
couldn't they do that in the horror
[Music]
world when you think of your favorite
horror films they're often continuously
running franchises people liked
Halloween so let's give them more
Halloween same with Nightmare on Elm
Street but not the conjuring one year
after its release Annabelle came out
giving a featurelength treatment to the
minor story at the beginning of the
conjuring that would be like if scream
was followed up by a spin-off of the
history of Drew Barrymore's character
who spoiler alert for a 27-year-old
movie dies in the first 15 minutes of
the film but of course the filmmakers
didn't do that they just did Scream 2
which followed characters from Scream
one on a new slashing Adventure like the
MCU The Conjuring expands the universe
around its characters the warens
Annabelle and the nun all have their own
sandalon franchises which have
connective tissue across movies but then
they'll also cross over like how the
Warren show up in the final Annabelle
movie the strength of doing a shared
universe is that you get to bounce
around with completely different
[Music]
Vibes but there's one more thing that
makes the conjuring Universe stand out
as a massive success they make a huge
bang for their Buck thanks to their
reasonably small bu budgets this is
because they're often haunted house
films and when you're mainly using one
location you have fewer variables more
control and can shoot way faster and
they're not just Successful by horror
metrics compare the return on investment
of the budget versus the box office to
other shared universes and the results
are impressive to say the
least Ed Warren passed away in 2006
Lorraine Warren passed away in 2019 in
their 61 years of marriage the couple
investigated over 10,000 cases with no
sign of The Conjuring universe's
popularity slowing down there are still
so many stories left to tell hey it's me
the ghost that's coming to haunt you
forever and ever uh before I do that I
was told to read this card so let's
let's see what it says here huh uh first
off it says thank you so much for
watching this video I have no idea what
that means but uh anyways uh weird it it
also says if you were to go to vox.com
now and become a contributor I might not
be forced to haunt you for all etern V
uh you'd also receive fun extras like a
newsletter from Vox journalists
apparently this is the best way to
support our journalism and make sure
that Vox stays free also it'll keep me
from hovering around your room in the
dead or night so if you want to see more
videos like this and get some sleep go
to vox.com now see you in the next one
or tonight in your bedroom if you don't
contribute I I'll be there and I'm going
to haunt you beware all right
[Music]
bye